vous savez que c'est l'anniversaire de
quelqu'un d'extrêmement célèbre
aujourd'hui vous avez une petite idée
jacques chirac tout à fait chaque
syndicat
elle voulut sur jacques chirac c'est
l'anniversaire effectivement de l'un des
hommes politiques les plus populaires de
france 86 ans donc je me suis dit qu'est
ce que je pourrais bien faire pour
rendre hommage à jacques chirac qui
aujourd'hui adulé maintenant parce que
c'est vrai que je n'ai plus en exercice
un peu la marche tête de veau tête
devant alors c'était compliqué au
plateau de vous offrir at on fait savoir
en revanche je me suis dit ces
chroniqueurs là ils ont du talent ils
ont forcément commence mal mais bien sûr
que je crois en vous je pense que malgré
le fait que certains vous pensent pour
des bras cassés
vous avez quand même quelque chose en
vous et notamment je suis sur des
talents d'imitateur où le dollar va vous
demander aux uns et aux autres de nous
faire une petite imitation de jacques
chirac
vous avez invité jacques chirac oui j'ai
joué jacques chirac moi mais c'est vrai
que vous avez jamais jacques chirac
notre chance pour un adieu de gaulle et
bien sûr oui mais vraiment battant c'est
plus sain et ouais
c'est un que l'âge aidant c'est
nécessaire pour déjouer pris avec
humanité d'efforts et bien je vous
demande pas si vous savez faire à la
france
[Rires]
alors maintenant on va passer donc de
dire ça peut être très gênante mais je
vous en prie de toute façon c'est ça
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai des pommes
même fine
mes chers compatriotes c'était une
catastrophe et le faisais ça chaque
chien faisait faisait là bon il faisait
ça faisait ça et ça il est passé mais ça
c'était juste encore kelly père il fait
ça quand ils s'expriment et en écoutant
écossaise
pour emmanuel écossaise a que thèse je
ne suis pas en laponie parce que c'est
beau mais c'est loin et je préfère aussi
cher c'est jean reno cherchons la
définition du moment de solitude et sans
qu'on l'ait maintenant fait remarquer la
chute quand même la vie cracra et gelé
ces gens là jamais il faut bien les
fonctionnalités d un texte pas dans
l'imitation bien sûr
c'est beau mais c'est loin mais attendez
christine c'était beau celle où lui même
mes chers compatriotes et dans une cave
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis sortie demain sinon c'est
vraiment pour défendre le pouvoir
d'achat j'essaie de faire une voix
d'homme un camp mais oui oui bah ouais
bon d'accord c'est ça vient pas au
premier abord comme ça oui
nicolas alors il ya tellement de grain
et l'ivraie
vous avez rapporté qu'une aujourd'hui
si je peux me permettre limitation est
très réussie petit de l'information et
m'ont jamais toujours à bernard montiel
à aller montbernard courage garçons
alors bernadette non écrite et le
chaudron de courcel là alors attention à
la llc la classe et l'élégance et la
caution technique soit ridicule comme
les autres mais mais mais on va on va
voir plus de données en imitation
abracadabra dire que ça a été quand même
furtif
oui mon site web vous avez inventé ce
mot là dans un collectif dans une
réunion politique et je trouvais que
c'était assez gênant meyrinois là il
sait bien c'est chic c'est c'est tout
vous et on termine avec évidemment non
raymond pas de simples coûté ma chère
valérie les prévisions sont difficiles
surtout quand elle concerne l'avenir
bonne émission valeur merci
[Applaudissements]